hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played between Hikaru
Nakamura and ali reza furiosa in one of
Nakamura's knockouts on chess calm it's
a three minute game and although it's
not often you will see me analyzing
boots games as a Rashid Dinesh made you
know it does say that he who analyzes
bliss is stupid
but this game is simply too great not to
show and it features a really beautiful
theme a beautiful attack and it's it's
something you would see in Adolphe
understands a resume if he was you know
applying for chess club somewhere
it comes as suggestion from Paulo bun
seen me and I'm very happy that he
suggested it as it's very unlikely that
I would find this game on my own it's
from a four hour stream of Hikaru's and
well that's why I say that what I do is
that much easier because the subscribers
often suggest such lovely games and you
can also suggest the game by using the
hashtag suggestion or you can pretty
much suggest it anywhere
this game was suggested to me on Twitter
but yeah it is easier for me if you
suggested in the comments using the
hashtag suggestion so without further
ado let's check out this very nice game
and Nakamura opens with III it's
something he does very often during his
knock outs as most likely it gives him
you know a lot of flexibility and he
doesn't have to do well on opening
theory that much 'if I've a very
principled response if white isn't
interested in grabbing the center you
want to grab as many of the central
squares as possible b3 preparing to
develop the light square bishop we have
Knight to c6 and now comes c4
sorry the dark square Bishop Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 Bishop to b4 and now
Bishop to b2 developing the bishop not
allowing black to double white spawns
castles by ferocious and now comes
Knight to f3 if you remember earlier
eyes of Arusha a Grand Master from Iran
won 2nd place in my elite chess
tournament from when I reached 200,000
subscribers
he was only seconds the Andrew tank mr.
penguin rook to e8 defending the e5 pawn
and now come
Knight to d5 and here although it's it's
not a problem to capture on d5 if you
don't immediately see if you gain
anything but you usually don't want to
do it but capturing here wouldn't be a
problem here of course you don't have
anywhere to go with your knight but you
can make room for a knight on e5 while
also attacking it this Knight and here
it goes into a pretty forced variation
after captures captures you force the
bishop back Bishop to f8 and now capture
some b7 captures and after captures
white will be up upon but black will
have a significant lead in development
and white-skinned is still stuck in
their center so for a blitz game yeah
one with the favor black here so after
Knight d5 we have Bishop back to c5 as
the Bishop was attacked on C on before
Queen to c2 and now comes h6 not
allowing this h7 point to be a target
any time in the future and also taking
away the g5 Square from the night a3
preparing before Sophie Rosia stops at
with a5 Bishop to d3 and now d6
preparing to develop the light square
bishop and here we have Knight captures
on f6 with check by Nakamura Queen
captures and now Bishop to h7 check it's
a very interesting check because you can
also play Bishop 3 for immediately but
oops sorry about that and Nakamura goes
back up to h7 immediately and now you
don't really a black doesn't really have
problems with either King f8 to h8 King
to H it was played and only now Bishop
to b4 so I don't know if this in between
better to h7 really does something but I
will often play a move like this for
example if I'm playing a blue game or a
hyperbola game just to give my opponent
as many possibilities to waste time and
to make a mistake so perhaps this is a
one such technique Knight to e7 and now
until this Knight to e7 move it was very
hard for Nakamura to execute this d4
breakthrough because his King occupies
the same file as the rock on e8 so now
that the knight blocks the rook well
Nakamura can go for a breakthrough on
the Queen side he decides to go for this
central rake through each chapter son d4
pawn captures on d4 and now comes
Bishop to f5
much better to develop this bishop and
try to force a variation like D captures
on c5 Bishop captures Queen captures on
e4 and now Queen captures on b2 and here
after white wood castle you can simply
move the knight and black will have a
very nice game so instead instead of
capturing here nakamura just castles you
know Safety's first Bishop captures on
e4 Queen captures and now still he
doesn't react to this Bishop being under
attack on c5 but rather Knight to g6 he
brings more pieces in near Nakamura's
King but it comes with a sacrifice of a
pawn so nakamura snatches at Queen
captures on b7 and now comes Bishop to
b6 as the bishop was under attack and
you also have to protect the c7 pawn and
here after giving the position some
consideration Nakamura decided to go
before he wants to push c5 push this
bishop further back and start munching
all of these very nice pawns Knight to
f4 few rows are played this move very
quickly but I will also put a link to
this original video in the description
below so you can check that out as well
nakamura knows that you know it's
getting pretty crowded around his king
but still there's nothing concrete here
so he simply proceeds with his plan
c5 the bishop is under attack and here
it's not all that clear what to do if
Bishop to a7 then well you can either
capture on c7 or you can play rook a e1
I challenge this rock on e8 because this
rook is stuck at guarding the bishop on
a seven-hour white would have a much
better position here
another thing after c5 if you play D
captures on c5 then again you get the D
captures on c5 Bishop still has to move
back or you have to do something about
your Queen here but if Queen captures on
b2 then you can capture here and then
after characters captures you will not
be able to capture back as your queen
will be hanging so after Queen goes back
you will get this move and now white is
up two points for the moment and it's
very unclear if black will be able to
hold this
but either way either way it's a very
unpleasant position for fearo's yeah but
the move he plays next is is what
reminds me of
of a game by Adolph Anderson and if I
gave you like a half an hour to pause
the video and figure out or move the
sphero's you played most likely none of
you would find it but you are more than
welcome to prove me wrong and try to
pause the video here not to find the
best move but to find the move that the
most romantic move in case any of you
really have paused the video here and
found the romantic move congratulations
you are a very romantic person and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
here if you Rosa played d5 and d5 really
doesn't make sense but it does kind of
remind you of Anderson's immortal game
where he just did this to block the
Queens the Queen's diagonal as this will
be used in in the attack that is coming
so as Nakamura tries to figure out
what's going on here he basically says
okay this is a free piece and it is
indeed a free piece so he captures that
see captors on v6 and now furiosa does
not do anything about the situation
inside but rather he happily continues
to sacrifice his pieces Knight captures
on g2 and now Nakamura goes into
calculation as he calculates out loud he
says King captors and g2 queen is
attracting each one and now Queen to e4
that's not good for white and it is very
interesting that he stops his
calculation here and he doesn't go
further but actually it's still playable
of course now you see that the knight is
under attack and also pinned you can't
move it if king blocks then this will
result in a draw after a repetition like
this in g1 check check check check check
it will be a robot repetition but on the
other hand after this after this Knight
captures Angie - if you capture it and
this is in fact played a king h1 and 24
now you can go look to g1 and now after
Queen captures on f3 route blocks you
still have to do something about that
situation on the Queen side you cannot
bring the rook into the attack via any
any means as your other look is hanging
on a 8 so if you move it
what can always capture and still it
will be very hard
whatever happens to bring your other
look into the attack and while this
would be very much playable from white
and Nakamura stops his calculation there
and decides not to capture the night he
plays Knight to e5 and okay 95 also an
excellent move takes away the g6 square
NDF 3 squared from blacks Queens so no
tricks are possible here but furiosa
doesn't care he simply plays rook
captures on e5 so it's not only an
exchange sacrifice as he's also giving
up his rook on a8 so nakamura captures
it as it does come with check we have
Queen captures on AAT this is with check
King to h7 and now comes D captures on
e5 and now feel free to pause the video
here and find the idea of euros ahead
with the black pieces so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you have just created
this beautiful online immortal game and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show the idea is Queen to f3 you
have to prevent the King from capturing
the knight but also more importantly
that the Queen from f3 is guarding the
d5 pawn so Queen chapters on d5 is not
possible but here it is there is no
defense against Knight to f4 Knight to
f4 followed by Queen to G - checkmate it
is very hard to prevent this for example
if you try something like rook F d1 to
capture here simply 92 a4 and you there
is no escape even if you try to escape
with your king for example King if 1 2 e
1 2 D 2 now Queen 2 H 1 will be
checkmate as the knight is covering e 2
and G 2 so here Nakamura really so much
material but nothing to do the two rooks
are useless the bishop controls the dark
squares so a useless piece for this
light square attack the Queen has no say
as the pawn that's a beautiful confit
rules are pushed to d5 controls the
entire board here so Nakamura has no
choice but to play Queen captures on d5
Nakamura gives up the Queen Queen
captures and now comes Rock a to D one
with f3
white could still continue to play this
game although it would be very difficult
but here after rook a to d1 simply
allows Queen back to f3 now Knight to f4
is still a threat nakamura tries to give
more pieces to get the Queen out of
there Queens after Sun d3 is played and
here be captures on c7 so there's no way
to prevent the pawn from cleaning as a
rock 2 c1 will always be possible but if
you just simply plays Knight to a4 and
Hiro Nakamura realizes that the same
idea still applies only via different
squares and here we also have a nice
photo it's from Nakamura's knockouts
this is Nakamura's face when he realized
that Knight to f4 also wins the game
very nicely there we have it I do hope
you enjoyed that
why doesn't like to have four wins well
it doesn't really matter what black
plays if you simply promote to a queen
then comes Queen to g6 check King moves
Queen to G to checkmate
and on the other hand after Knight to f4
if you try something like f3
blocking this then Queen to g6 wins
again but even greater is Queen to c2
threatening checkmate via Queen to g2
and now after white prevents this rope
to f2 now you can win in two different
ways as you've blocked the Kings escape
route via team to f2 Queen to g6 check
you can go King to f1 but now comes the
Queen to be one check and now the rook
is blocking the king's escaped v f2 the
knight is blocking e 2 and the g2 so you
have to block with the bishop and Queen
captures on c1 will be checkmate and
also there is a different checkmate
after Knight to f4 if you play f3 simply
Queen to c2 rook blocks and now Knight
to h3 check and now a very nice King
hunt begins if you go to h1 then simply
Queen captures followed by Queen to f1
checkmate
but if you try to escape King g2 then
comes Queen captures captures captures
on f3 with check came to h4 and now you
will see the checkmate in one that is g5
this is checkmate as Queen is covering
all of the light squares so a beautiful
beautiful game after Bishop
B captors on c7 furo is a played Knight
to f4 and it was in this position that
he
Nakamura resigned this game so yeah
there we have it one more time that's
the that's the face after night to a for
it hurts definitely as you know he had
it he had if he had it and then he just
didn't have it anymore but yeah that's
the game I do hope you enjoyed it a nice
Bliss game you know to mix it up a bit
before going into the basket FIFRA
versus basket finally I would like to
thank David David Preston Myka Wagner
Michael berry ever David Beltran Pinto
and the zebra actor for contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting content feel free to
use hashtag suggestion to suggest your
own and if there are any gamers amongst
my subscribers what are your thoughts on
the new Diablo immortal that is coming
up on mobile I thank you all and I'll
see you soon